alexa spegne quadrati
alexa spegne lampada
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video dove alex ha dei problemi di
sentimenti a quanto pare molto siamo
dati sul classico cure e nei solito che
facciamo tramite instagram dove vi ho
chiesto di farmi le domande stavolta
scomode ma in realtà sono sempre scomoda
e solo perché cercavo di esse di farvi
essere un po più più cattivi perché sono
sempre domande buone domande
se dobbiamo faster userfarm allora
partiamo subito e vediamo se riesco a
essere sincero l'obiettivo come sempre
essere sincero al cento per cento c'è
veramente quando risponde una domanda è
questa la cosa complicata ma lo faremo
quindi non è un click days sono
totalmente sincero anche con quale scopo
delle sdo partiamo dalla prima ostuni
klose che l'armadio di ostuni fattiva
vaghe armadio che mi chiede se è mai
uscito con una tua ex mentre vidi
danzato una volta sola e successo la
persona con cui stavo lo sapeva ed è
ovviamente da tutto ciò era era una pera
giusto un incontro per chiacchierare
adesso non mi ricordo solo che state
pensando male marchionne celli ma non è
successo niente la sua un incontro per
chiacchierare per non ci vedevamo da
tanto e comunque la persona con cui
stavo lo sapeva anche quindi francesco
chiede faresti un video assieme a rocco
siffredi a mo di terapeuta come
correlata prima volta allora caro tu non
sei mai visto i video di rocco da
terapeuta diciamo che poi la trama è
totalmente diversa da quello che ti
aspetti quindi non è certo quando lo fai
che prescriva tv un di wow
ragazzi questi qua diciamo che ho preso
questi perché xl era finito
questa è bellissima aiuto più ragazzo
più playstation playstation ho avuto
tutte e cinque le playstation finora di
relazioni serie serie c è proprio
relazioni bene uscite
indicazione ho avute 4 quindi in realtà
auto più playstation però se contiamo
anche quelle non serie più ragazze però
bella domanda come vivi il calo delle
visualizzazioni da spronato o
demoralizzato e in realtà nessuna delle
due non me ne fregava quasi unica non mi
hanno spronato nei demoni cioè ma vivo
totalmente tramiti qualcosa di più
quando hai dato che non so cosa voglia
dire non so cosa volesse dire matteo
comunque vi racconto sta roba al volo
quando ha dato il primo bacio ci ho
messo mi pare tipo 10 15 minuti a darlo
c'è la mia prima ragazza appunto era con
gli occhi chiusi tra l'altro per
agevolarmi in questa cosa no visto che
ero timido e io nonostante sapevo che
lei volesse quel bacio nonostante fossi
sicuro degli tutto era anche ad occhi
chiusi e non sono riuscito per 15 minuti
poi mi sono buttato è stato pub a mia
mamma mia non so perché così tanto io
ero veramente molto più timido di adesso
non so come mai non ve lo so dire
qualche ricordo incredibile quando hai
guardato
mi ha fatto morire perché ho messo i
colori ho capito esattamente quello di
cui sta parlando per la prima volta
vincenzo sei stato un grande è
bellissimo come l'arte a volte riesca a
trasmettere più delle parole va bene ero
alle medie mi sa perché qualcuno c'era
sul telefonino massima durata a letto
comunque se mi fa ridere che sono tutte
scomode però giustamente se ho detto
domande scomode mi dovevo aspettare che
fossero tutte in sé requa 99 per cento
sono inerenti al sesso questo è scomoda
sul serio perché devo rispondere da
serio e mi green già diciamo che allora
io ho il problema vabbè che avete perché
l'avevo già raccontato del fatto che
quando stavo in ansia una volta non so
se ce l'ho più e sta cosa qua comunque
quando stavo inanza che una persona
della quale mi portava tanto non
riuscivo a ravenna e rosa bene ride però
c'è la parte brutta della medaglia che
questa che la prima volta in generale
quando me ne frega tanto di una persona
può capitare che faccia cilecca quel
altre sono a posto tutte la parte
positiva della medaglia che io non ho
problemi da quel punto c'è nel senso io
posso anche durare un sacchi simo non so
perché ho un autocontrollo parecchio
pesante quindi non te la saprei dire
però volendo possono durare
cioè posso durare il praticamente
infinito non so come mai non so voi ma
io questo questa magia o altre
negatività che quella della prima volta
quanto successo però questa su questa
sono a posto quindi da tanto non so
perché non però potrei anche non
andiamo avanti perdonereste un'infedeltà
allora no non la perdonerei perché
allora io ho una donna però non voglio
fare noi dare una risposta chilometrica
perché non voglio far due palle così a
nessuno quando tu stai con una persona
ok approvi del sentimento per un'altra
persona
non ha senso che turno che tu stiamo
ancora mio personale quindi è proprio
questo discorso di sensi con una ragazza
che si dovesse sito innamorare di un
altro non ha senso che sia con me ok non
suoi capi verbi tutta la frase perché ho
capito quindi è un po quello discorso è
come una questione di stupidità può
succedere ok può succedere come cosa
però poi non ci voglio più avere niente
da fare cioè potrei perdonarla anche
volendo perché il discorso di perdonare
comunque diverso cioè io posso perdonare
una cosa ma non stare comunque insieme
ci ho capito potrei anche dire ok è
successo di avere questa scappatella qua
va bene ok ti perdono nel senso che ti
capisco c'è posso capirne la non lo
possono capire però se è proprio
successo una volta lo posso capire però
comunque non voglio più stare con te
capito perché mi sento
poco rispettato se mai stato con un
amico che alla fine che alla finte ti
pugnala alle spalle sembra una di quelle
domande che leggo su preferiresti quando
traduce google traduttore malissimo
allora non mi è mai successo anche
perché io ho tanti amici ma di very very
very very cioè nel senso amici intimi di
infanzia con i quali ho condiviso
la mia adolescenza la mia vita hanno
veramente pochi dell'amicizia quelle
bere tipo di fratellanza durano da un
sacco di anni e sono veramente poche
selezionate quindi da loro non potrei
mai aspettarmi una cosa del genere anche
perché facciamo di tutto l'uno per
l'altro
se un mio amico
più terra terra dovesse fare una cosa
del genere non mi fai non mi ferirebbe
così tanto perché non ce le persone che
non ho come amici strettissimi non
potrebbero farmi così male da
pugnalarmi ti piacerebbe cambiare sesso
per un giorno si sarebbe figo anche per
capire il tipo your name bellissimo ma
giusto per capire insomma capi capire
però i non capitale proprio del giorno
delle mie cose sarebbe un po una roba ma
pigliare niteròi 20 per cento
dovrei averlo sfiga preferisci torino
milano questo è comodissima perché in
base a cosa rispondi miti i nemici zico
il nemico l'altra città però vi posso
dire che le ho vissute entrambe in modi
completamente diversi perché io milano
vissuto veramente vissuto nel senso che
sono venuto a milano ho iniziato a
vivere nelle mie case e quelle che ho
cambiato perché la prima stava in
affitto ora sono in questa è quindi un
po proprio vissuto milano ok torino
parte il fatto che a parte fatto io sono
vicino a torino in un paesino vicino a
torino non proprio a torino quindi l'ho
vissuta da ragazzo che va in centro che
quindi dovrei dovrei prendere casa a
torino e capire come dare questa
risposta sono totalmente diverse quindi
non saprei dire però che questo io e lei
mi sia piaciuto seguitemi su instagram
anche perché lì appunto vi faccio la
storia dove potete farmi le domande è
comunque fatemi sapere anche qua sotto
nei commenti cosa ne pensate se volete
farmi delle domande più specifiche
i ragazzi vi saluto vi do un bacino
spero che vi sia piaciuto iscritti al
canale lasciato il tasto lasciate perché
non c'era prima su youtube il tasto mi
piace lasciatelo voi e schiacciatelo
pure dopo che avete lasciato scegliamo
come sempre al prossimo video belle
ragazze
[Musica]